>>> ACCORDING TO PENTAGON
OFFICIALS, AT LEAST 600, THESE
ARE SOME OF THEM.
CRUISE MISSILES HITTING A TOWN
OF CENTRAL UKRAINE AND CAN BE
FIRED FROM LONG DISTANCES AWAY.
THIS FAR INTO THE WAR AND RUSSIA
DOESN'T HAVE FULL AIR
SUPERIORITY OVER THE BATTLE
FIELD ACCORDING TO WESTERN
OFFICIALS.
OUR NEXT GUEST WANTS TO TAKE
STEPS TO MAKE SURE THEY NEVER
DO.
ADAM KINZINGER JOINS US NOW.
YOU'VE BEEN CALLING FOR BACKING
THE IDEA OF A NO FLY ZONE, WHICH
IS SOMETHING THE UKRAINIAN AND
PRESIDENT AND UKRAINIAN
OFFICIALS ARE REALLY PUSHING
FOR.
I TALKED TO THE FORMER U.S.
AMBASSADOR TO UKRAINE STEVEN
PFEIFFER AND HE SAID THE ONE
MAJOR DRAW BACK OF A NO FLY ZONE
BESIDES THE OBVIOUS, IT PROVOKES
POTENTIALLY DIRECT CONFLICT, YOU
KNOW, OF AN AMERICAN PLANE
SHOOTING DOWN A RUSSIAN PLANE.
THE AMBASSADOR SAID THEY WOULD
HAVE TO BOMB ANTI WAR WEAPONS IN
BELARUS IN ADDITION TO RUSSIAN
ANTI WAR ASSETS IN UKRAINE.
TALK TO ME ABOUT YOUR SUPPORT
FOR THE NO FLY ZONE AND THOSE
ARGUMENTS AGAINST IT.
>> LOOK, ANDERSON THERE IS RISK.
I'M NOT GOING TO DENY THAT AND
WE SHOULD OBVIOUSLY LOOK AT THAT
WITH EYES WIDE OPEN.
YOU KNOW, I THINK THERE IS RISK
IN AN ACTION, TOO, AT THE
MOMENT.
WHAT I FEAR IN THE LONG TERM IS
THAT IF RUSSIA ULTIMATELY DOES
TAKE CONTROL OF KYIV OR ALL OF
UKRAINE OR MOST OF UKRAINE AND
WE WAKE UP EVERY MORNING AND
CONTINUE TO SEE THOUSANDS UPON
THOUSANDS OF CIVILIANS KILLED
AND ALL THESE TRAGIC STORIES,
THERE WILL BE A MOMENT WHERE WE
DECIDE WE HAVE TO AND BY THAT
TIME, I THINK YOU'RE
SIGNIFICANTLY IN A MUCH MORE
RISKY SPOT BECAUSE MUCH MORE
RUSSIAN EQUIPMENT WILL BE MOVED
IN.
I WANT TO BE CLEAR.
THERE IS OPTIONS.
THERE IS A NO FLY ZONE OVER
UKRAINE AND WESTERN UKRAINE AND
A HUMANITARIAN NO FLY ZONE.
I THINK WE'VE DONE A LOT AS THE
U.S. AND ALLIES SO THIS ISN'T AN
ATTACK ON THE RESPONSE SO FAR.
I FEAR WE'RE GOING TO GET TO THE
MOMENT WHERE WE'RE GOING TO BE
COMPELLED TO AND WE SHOULD NOT
FEAR RUSSIA IN THAT CONTEXT.
>> YOU'VE REACHED TWO
INTERESTING IDEAS, WHICH A LOT
OF PEOPLE HAVEN'T TALKED ABOUT.
I WANT TO ASK ABOUT THEM
FURTHER.
ONE OF THEM IS BASICALLY KIND OF
AN AIR CORRIDOR, HUMANITARIAN
AIR CORRIDOR THAT I GUESS WOULD
BE PROTECTED BY U.S. PLANES OR
NATO PLANES OR ALLIED COUNTRY
PLANES OR COUNTRIES WHO ARE
WILLING TO IF NOT NATO PER SE
AND THAT WOULD, WHAT, ALLOW THE
FLIGHT OF SUPPLIES IN?
>> YEAH, SO IF YOU THINK OF IT
SIMILAR TO A BERLIN AIRLIFT IF
YOU CAN PROTECT A CORRIDOR, YOU
CAN ALLOW PLANES TO FLY IN AND
DROP SUPPLIES OR ARMAMENTS.
IF IT'S AN AGREED UPON ONE, THE
RUSSIANS VIOLATED EVERY ATTEMPT
TO HAVE HUMANITARIAN CORRIDORS
SO FAR, YOU WOULD LIMIT IT TO
SUPPLIES AND MEDICAL.
WE HAVE TO LOOK AT THE DIFFERENT
VARIATIONS OF WHAT WE CAN DO ON
A NO FLY ZONE.
THE IMPORTANT THING IS THIS.
THE OLD SOVIET UNION USED TO
THREATEN THE USE OF NUCLEAR
WEAPONS ALL THE TIME.
IF UKRAINE ENDS UP DEFEATING
RUSSIA, WHICH WE PRAY FOR, IF
YOU THINK VLADIMIR PUTIN IS
CRAZY ENOUGH TO USE NUKES
AGAINST NATO AND THE WEST FOR
DEFENDING THE SKIES OF A
SOVEREIGN COUNTRY THAT INVITED
THEM TO DO IT, I THINK WE HAVE
TO BE REALISTIC THAT HE MAY VERY
WELL JUST USE THEM ON UKRAINE IF
HE LOSES.
HE'S A CRAZY MAN.
WE'VE DONE A GREAT JOB STANDING
UP TO HIM.
THERE IS A FEW MORE THINGS I'D
DO.
THIS IS A MOMENT HE WON'T GO
QUIETLY.
>> YOU'VE ALSO TALKED ABOUT THE
IDEA OF -- WHICH YOU MENTIONED
PREVIOUSLY ABOUT A NO FLY ZONE
IN THE WEST OF UKRAINE.
I'M IN LVIV, WHICH IS MUCH
CLOSER TO THE POLISH BORDER.
IT'S THE TRANSIT POINT FOR
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE
WHO ARE FLEEING, THEY COME TO
THE LVIV TRAIN STATION TRYING TO
GET FURTHER WEST OF POLAND,
ROMANIA AND THE LIKE.
THERE IS EVEN TALK OF IF KYIV
FELL THAT PERHAPS THERE WOULD BE
UKRAINIAN GOVERNMENT IN CHARGE
IN LVIV AND THAT WOULD BE THE
SITE, THE SEED OF POWER.
WHAT WOULD A NO FLY ZONE IN
WESTERN UKRAINE ACCOMPLISH?
>> YEAH, IT WOULD BE BASICALLY
THAT.
IT WOULD BE PROTECTING AN AREA
FOR -- IF CIVILIANS NEED TO
FLEE, TO FLEE, THEY CAN BE
PROTECTED.
IT ALLEVIATES PRESSURE OBVIOUSLY
ON EUROPE WHO WILL TAKE -- YOU
KNOW, WE'VE HAD A MILLION REF
-- REFUGEES.
IT ALLOWS A PLACE IF GOD FORBID
KYIV DOES FALL TO HAVE THAT
GOVERNMENT AND EXILE YOU
MENTIONED TO CONTINUE TO TRAIN,
EQUIP AND SUPPORT THE UKRAINIAN
ARMY AS THEY TRY TO TAKE BACK
THE REST OF UKRAINE.
KEEP IN MIND, I THINK IF WE GET
TO A POINT AND THIS IS WHERE WE
HAVE TO REMEMBER AS WE MAKE
DECISIONS TODAY WHERE WE SEE
KYIV FALL OR SEE SIGNIFICANT
PART OF UKRAINE FALL OR GOD
FORBID A DEFEAT OF THE UKRAINIAN
ARMY, TAKING BACK UKRAINE WILL
BE FAR BLOODIER THAN ANYTHING
WE'VE SEEN TODAY.
>> YOU SIT ON THE COMMITTEE FOR
ENERGY AND COMMERCE.
WE HEARD A NUMBER OF PEOPLE
TALKING FOR A BAN ON RUSSIAN OIL
AND GAS AT THE U.S., DO YOU
AGREE WITH THAT IDEA OF A BAN
AND DO YOU THINK IT SOMETHING
THAT ACTUALLY MIGHT HAPPEN?
>> I THINK IT'S CERTAINLY
GAINING STEAM.
I THINK IT SHOULD HAPPEN,
ABSOLUTELY.
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE HAVE TO BE
READY FOR EVEN HIGHER ENERGY
PRICES.
I THINK THERE IS AN
UNDERSTANDING THAT THIS IS IN
ESSENCE A SMALL PRICE TO PAY
PARTICULARLY IF YOU LOOK WHAT IS
GOING ON IN UKRAINE AND PUT
YOURSELF IN THEIR SHOES, THAT'S
A COST OF DEFENDING FREEDOM AND
WE HAVE OVER MAYBE AS OF TODAY,
YOU KNOW, 700 MILLION SOME
BARRELS IN THE PETROLEUM
RESERVE.
THAT'S WHAT THIS IS FOR.
FOR THESE MOMENTS.
I THINK WE HAVE TO DO IT.
THIS IS THE ONE THING RUSS